yes
i am in japan i swear gundam javert
japan
books fairy japan
they finally arrived making me feel a
little bit smarter all right so i asked
you guys to ask me questions about my
move in japan because i figured maybe
there are some and i like to talk about
it so let's do it number one
favorite thing about japan
it always has to boil down to one thing
doesn't it as much as i like for that to
be the case just to make it easier to
answer this question that everyone wants
to know are you are you moving to japan
what do you like about it well actually
there's many things that i like about
japan i couldn't really okay i'm bored
you shouldn't say one thing just say
anime
it's complicated i just like it here
okay what is something you just found
out about japan that you dislike
that's a good question it's my first
month here japan can do no wrong
everything is amazing i love it let me
enjoy my honeymoon face with this
country please i'm sure there will be
things oh actually i did find it strange
how people ride on bicycles and then on
the sidewalk but now that i have a bike
i kind of get it
how do the people around respond to you
guys like total strangers or some of
them recognize you yes i still get
recognized but it's usually
foreigners living here that recognize me
i've never been approached by a japanese
person although sometimes strangers just
start speaking english to me and i'm
kind of confused by it but i do think
it's because people are nice and they
want to practice english maybe i don't
know favorite food in japan
sushi
you can't go wrong with the fish herds
and as an epic pescatarian
i love the fish here i get to enjoy the
fish here very good fish here
uk
i can say it now because i don't leave
you in you anymore your fish
sucks it's bad
what's up with that
fish and chips
it's good you're that's okay other fish
before we continue quick word from
sponsor to celebrate me moving to japan
opera gx the greatest browser of all
time has made
a surprise for me
uh with opengl errors apparently i think
that's actually on my end
uh we got the pewdiepie bed
this is how we arrived in our private
jet that has a pool
oh this is the team that built it sick
so opera diaz has this thing called the
gamer house or something it's so funny i
love it so they built me one in
minecraft
oh my recording studio let's go
yes it's like i'm walking in on myself
hey we got the pewdiepie videos let's go
so a feature that is amazing
and with the opera gx it's just change
of themes which you can change
oh that's so cool they work how do they
do that
you can change your theme of your
browser and they all look sexy as hell i
would recommend the pewdiepie one which
you can use by downloading opera gx in
the link in description but they have a
ton of other cool stuff as well this is
so cool
all right where does this go
of course another great feature about
the rigs is the sidebar
you want to use spotify one click away
baby it's always there you want to use
discord one click away
twitch one click away what's that always
there it's super convenient honestly
game changer i feel like other browsers
are starting to copy it but they are on
top of opera gx is on top of all the new
features love it
love the sidebar
this is how hot your cpu will be without
gx control
do you hate your computer or something
why are you letting your computer suffer
for no reason just activate gx control
baby you can limit your rhyme usage hot
tab killer amazing feature find out
which tabs are the ones that take up the
most of your computing power
cpu limiter as well
incredible feature
oh my god sven
and
darksvan
oh oh what is that
you made it all the way to japan
yes
oh you guys get your own big screen
oh my god it's jurgen
yes
we made it all the way to japan i got my
japanese cars gx cookie cleaner
oh my god
sushi conveyor belt i love it
let's clear those cookies
yeah i get those cookies cleared
gs oh nice should we play
[Music]
it is not super necessary but god damn
is it nice that it's there
let's check out the gx corner baby
so we have the ability of course to turn
dark mode
on or off whoa what's gonna happen
i was sick
hey we got the pewdiepie
opera gx theme beautiful
one of the finest looking one i got if i
say so myself they also have the ability
to force dark mode
some websites are sociopaths and they
don't allow dark mode opera gx says no
dogmo protect gamer's precious eyes they
also have a feature to check out my
latest videos if you use the link in the
description that latest version of the
download will have an animated theme as
well so definitely check that out so if
you already have opera downloaded i
recommend checking out the animated
theme they have a ton of great animated
other themes
the game suggestion feature i personally
found a ton of great games through and
people ask hey how did you find this
game when i'm like
it's a secret
it sounds like such a fake commercial
it's actually true that it has happened
that's such a cool idea i love this
thank you opera gx i highly recommend
checking out link is in the description
to download it's available on your phone
as well which i recommend as well
because it's really easy to send files
through your phone they didn't show that
but they have a feature where you can
share files from your phone to your
computer super easily if you have the
browser and that's the end of the
sponsored segment believe it or not this
was a sponsored segment
all right back to the video how has
japan affected your lifestyle and
content creation
uh have you been watching my channel i'm
a vlogger now thank you for all the
support on the vlogs i really appreciate
it that's just been an undying love and
support in the comments and uh normally
i'm a bit more private and i don't like
to share too much stuff i like i hardly
post on instagram and social media
anymore but it's been really fun to
share this journey with you guys and
then all the positivity just makes me
want to do more so
thank you what was the first japanese
dish you ate i think uh a rice ball tuna
mayo rice ball
can't go wrong with that what's the new
hobby you want to get into i look
forward to build more gundams while i'm
here i have this one that i bought also
two years ago
that's gonna be epic
i like building on them it's very fun
and relaxing and you should try it but
i'm good on the new hobby front i'm
preoccupied learning japanese as well
what was the most oh my god of course
japan moment you had so far i think when
we try to apply for the bank account
i brought a whole folder of paper
thinking they're gonna ask me for a
bunch of weird papers and i will bring
every single paper i have and that still
wasn't enough so that felt very of
course japan
uh how is the vending machine live i
love it i love it i have like 10 vending
different vending machines in my 100
meter radius and it's incredible how are
gyms in japan did you bring your workout
equipment the nearest gym to me is well
i wasn't that impressed by it it's not
bad but i prefer to work out at home so
i got myself a half power rack
i haven't gotten the weights yet but i
really look forward to use it i know
they have really good gyms here though
o'connor told me they have amazing gyms
with like pools and saunas and laymen
and bayme uh
i just i don't think it's worth it for
me i enjoy the
flexibility of working out at home if
not for japan where else would you have
gone to see this is a really tough thing
for us since we weren't sure if we were
actually going to be able to move or not
we kept thinking like okay well what do
we do we were here where were they and i
think it was so stressful because it
would always just come back to but we
still really want to go to japan like
that's what we want to do
you know i'm sure there's other great
options out there japan is what we
wanted to move to having to prolong the
process and making it so difficult to
move here it just reassured us even more
that that's what we actually really
wanted people who complain about how hot
it is in japan doesn't know what it's
like to live in singapore
i've been to singapore during uh
the humid place of things there was a
thunderstorm so it was super hot but no
actually you know what some people think
it's hot in singapore and japan
i didn't think
i didn't even notice
compare japanese lifestyles to swedish
lifestyle i could be wrong but i do feel
like japanese and swedish people are
quite similar in a more reserved kind of
way of acting for better or worse i feel
very comfortable around
that kind of people
in america it's completely normal to
just start talking to strangers that's
super weird here and it's super weird in
sweden and i do like talking to
strangers sometimes having small talk i
don't mind that but i feel more safe and
comfortable in places like this
i don't know what else to describe it i
see scandinavian products all over the
place i think they have a similar sort
of feel for
interior design and
furniture and
very minimal and aesthetic taste i like
it will you make a camping video in
japan yes
i would love to go camping i'm very
excited to do that we me and martin
watched his anime called euro camp and i
told joey about it and apparently joey
went to that place they went in your
camp you can camp out right in front of
mount fuji and it looks amazing me and
mars i love to camp we usually tend to
rent a van though to make it a little
easier for us and the dogs i think we'll
be okay i would love i would love to do
it the biggest surprise about japan even
after all your research i nothing has
surprised me so far because i get this
question a lot and the thing is we've
been to japan before
many times we would go every single year
we knew what we were getting ourselves
into moving into this country basically
is what i'm trying to say hey pewds so
happy for you does anyone in japan give
you looks because you're a foreigner
people keep describing like the angry
look
i just tend to avoid eye contact
normally anyway because uh out of habit
of not wanting to get recognized so i
don't really know what the look is that
people describe like the disappointing
look uh i i haven't seen it yet how is
settling down there is it difficult now
that i have my setup i feel really good
like having the chair again got my
desktop computer
my monitors my camera
there's still tweaks and stuff i want to
do a lot of it but
the general basic is here and it feels
amazing i love i love this office i'm so
happy with how it turned out i i really
want to do a setup tour what happened to
the pc elena sent you
i've answered this so many times that pc
has been a blessing and a curse because
i'm i was obviously super happy and
thankful for it it was a funny meme in a
video and a collab with linus
but people keep asking me about it i
gave it to a friend because it didn't
fit my office at the time the thing was
huge uh and i couldn't find any personal
use for it and i couldn't justify
sending my to japan i don't think it
would fit this room either was super
funny and i don't want to seem
ungrateful because it's a great gift but
you guys got to start googling a little
bit come on is marcia the young key to
your spoinky
she is the greatest junkie the most
amazing going key to my spoinky
wait is this sexual
did anime introduce you to japanese
culture
i think it probably did actually i
watched anime a lot when i was 18 but
that's not what drew me to japan i
didn't watch anime and was like i want
to go to japan although i do remember
the first time when i went here i was a
bit underwhelmed with how
little edge anime there is
like there are places you can go which
is smack full like akihabara and yeah i
guess a lot of bookstores and
convenience they sell manga but
it's not a thing everywhere what is an
underrated or unspoken about feature of
japan that you really like uh it's not
underrated or underspoken i think people
still know about it but people visit
japan to see all the quirky and wacky
and all the crazy toilets and the
vending machines the convenience the
amazing trains and all that i i really
like the more quiet love for nature
aspect of japan and more spiritual side
as well i think it's uh
the softer side of japan you know it has
a wacky crazy side but also softer side
which i really like how's the weather
there it's great it's nice to actually
see the sun are you enjoying not being
constantly recognized do you miss uh the
recognition at all i
never cared for attention i always smile
when i meet people and it genuinely like
brightens me up i mean that but and i
think people recognize this in my vlogs
that i can kind of let my guard down a
bit in public and that's also honestly
part of the reason why we like japan no
one knows who we are here and i really
enjoy that
as much as i like me me you guys i do
also enjoy that but also don't
misunderstand me i i always appreciate
people coming and just saying hi for a
bit have a lot of tattoos do you think
i'll have a problem went to japan
you'll be fine they know foreigners have
tattoos there's nothing weird about it
but you won't be allowed to go in most
onsens
you can maybe find a private one or a
foreigner friendly onsen usually should
be okay maybe uh it's worth trying at
least do you plan on staying in japan
for the rest of your life
bruh only thing i plan to do for the
rest of my life is staying with margie
so
i don't make plans for the rest of my
life actually
i will keep lifting for the rest of my
life and reading what's the defining
moment that made you want to move to
japan i think it was in
2018 when myanmar say had stayed there
for a month and at the end of it we
realized it was such a good time that we
didn't want to really go back
and we both just imagined hey what if we
actually moved here for a while what
would that look like would that work and
we started looking into it a lot of
things changed along that from that
moment to where we are now but i'm just
so glad to be here
are you getting a jdm car or example
nissan skyline i love the skyline it's a
sexy ass vehicle i haven't seen one here
actually but i did see a volvo 740
decked out here and i was like damn
that's what i should have i'm not big on
cars to be honest i i know very little
but being in japan and trying to find
the car that i want to buy here has
really made me appreciate well-designed
japanese cars are they're just
incredible how hard is it to not know
anyone or do you know someone already we
know joe anaki tokidoki emma i met with
connor he's really cool there seems to
be a ton of other youtubers that i would
love to meet her as well garn a
fellow pizza crust hater you know i
already know people and i look forward
to meet even more people how is it
socially being arrested in japan as a
foreigner socially i want to move but i
don't know now that i'm showing this
whole process of moving and all that i
want people to be mindful that yes it
was difficult to move here especially
with the pandemic happening and i'm sure
it'll be easier but from what i hear and
most people that move here find it
really difficult because of the work
culture being so much harder than they
think or
really struggling because basically just
working all the time and having very
little money and yada yada yada i don't
think my vlogs are an accurate portrayal
of what it's like
being a resident here and visiting
though amazing and you should definitely
do it does japan feel very crowded
wherever you go uh no
not at all actually people are always
moving tokyo is huge so you always have
to be aware of other people around you
no matter what where you are or what
you're doing um
but where i live no it's not crowded if
you go to shinjuku station at 5pm yes
you will it will be very crowded but
most of the time
a ton of space how much does it cost to
move to japan well
for me
it came with a big cost
japan taxes uh it's uh
is uh very strict and that's definitely
something i
waved while considering moving here but
i made most of my money it'd be silly
for me to
not move somewhere because because of
taxes what is your favorite book on
japanese history either non-fiction or
fiction i read
sorting sword the sword and christian
fin mum i don't know if that's how you
say it it was written by
ruth benedict an anthropologist that was
hired by the american government during
world war ii as an attempt to understand
the japanese people and their mindset at
the time which
especially then was really hard to
understand it seemed almost
contradictory hence the title sword and
the flower basically chrysanthemum
how a country can be so hard and soft at
the same time it's it's two opposites
and two contradictions and
sort of breaking that down
some people say it's not accurate some
people say it is i just find it really
interesting because it's generally based
on a really really old mindset obviously
things are different and
change what are you using to learn
japanese mainly i'm using anki which is
really good for vocabulary you basically
get a bunch of flashcards that you make
yourself which i like too because then
if i want to learn a word i just put it
in my own library and the flashcards
will repeat them for me i think it's a
fun way to do it i'm also using today i
think it's called it's an app that lets
you
read simplified japanese news and they
have translations and dictionary and
yeah that seems okay for me for now i'm
trying to do stuff that i think is fun
and focus on that to be honest so i'll
let you know if uh it's successful or
not people get so mad at me for saying
that i don't know japanese fluently or
like i don't know any japanese i said
which wasn't true it's not true i just
kind of feel like it doesn't come
naturally to me learning japanese and
i'd rather downplay
[Laughter]
how much i've actually spent trying to
learn japanese and surprise people as
opposed to
saying yes i've started so much and but
then i can probably get a sense out or
something like that and also like i
mentioned in my vlog people say like oh
i speak a little bit of english and then
they're fluent here it's just kind of
odd to me so at first people ask if i
speak japanese i would also say a little
and then it's like oh god i don't speak
a little this is impossible i zoom i
read it people someone made it was just
making a joke at that oh he had three
years to
wait to move to japan and he didn't
learn the language he just posted a
bunch of memes or something like that
the thing is and i think people don't
realize it since this process was so
difficult for so long we didn't think we
would actually be going i was actually
sure that we weren't going to go for a
while so i kind of stopped learning
japanese because i thought well what's
the point and if we do end up going i'm
just going to learn quicker if i'm
actually there
but after a while i decided you know
what i
actually really enjoy studying japanese
i think it's really fun i read all these
uh things about how good it is for your
brain to learn a new language and it's
really healthy for you to do so i
thought you know what [ __ ] even if we
don't end up moving to japan i actually
still want to learn japanese because i
enjoy doing it so i would actually
recommend people to learn language not
to
i know that sounds preachy for someone
that hasn't even learned the damn
language yet but it's fun i like it
i'm not good like i said it doesn't come
naturally at all to me it's completely
different than learning a western
language i think but it's a challenge
and i'm not giving up
anything you miss about brighton i i
knew i would miss this and it's seeing
the ocean every day you kind of take it
for granted when you do live there
though but uh yeah it's uh it's always
nice to see it it's our language bearing
when having a casual conversation like
asking for directions what kind of
shocked me right away is that people
speak very fast
and even words that i do know i hear
them say it and it doesn't register
right away so it takes me a while uh so
yeah it's difficult why do swedes don't
feed guests at home
okay
yes
i've seen this this is on reddit as well
where
someone posted like what was the
weirdest thing about different countries
culture growing up and someone posted
that in sweden when they were a kid and
they were hanging out with their friend
at their friend's house when it was time
to eat he wasn't invited to eat together
with the whole family the whole of
internet is just shocked and appalled by
this that they wouldn't feed their
guests
and i will agree i it sounds super weird
i didn't you know there's stuff that you
don't realize growing up because you
think it's normal everywhere just like
how swedish pancakes are swedish
pancakes and not all of europe pancakes
i remember the rules were if you plan to
go to a friend's house in advance then
it's a given that you will eat with with
their family you know no questions asked
let's go eat
but if it was decided on the day hey uh
my friend is coming over we're just
gonna hang out they would ask you okay
do you want to stay over for dinner and
if the answer is yes
then you would have to call your parents
and ask your parents is it okay that i
eat over at my friend's house tonight
and then the other option then is if
your parents say yes or no you know
maybe they say no because no we already
bought the food or prepared just the
right amount for all of us and you'll
just be wasting food if you don't eat
with us so no you'll eat with us and
then it's like okay fine if that's the
case then yeah you will just wait in the
room of your friend while your friend
goes down to eat with their family
because
it would just be kind of weird sitting
at the dining table and not eat anything
plus it was awesome if your friend had
to go and eat and was like oh cool i'll
just keep playing
i'll just keep playing for 15 minutes
great and the other option i guess is if
your parents say yes then yeah you'll
just eat with uh your friend i don't get
it it sounds really weird to me that
someone wasn't at least asked
like okay i'm gonna eat now do you want
to eat with us or are you eating at home
that that to me sounds weird although
the whole concept of waiting in the room
that's totally a thing don't want to be
all like no sweden is the most
hospitable country i don't think maybe
we are but uh
it does seem kind of odd that would be a
weird thing for anyone i think in sweden
are you planning to see the real-life
gundam in japan uh
yeah i know they're taking it down in
yokohama so i really want to see it
first there's another one in odaiba as
well which i've seen is super cool but
the yokohama one is supposed to move
which i want to see the moving one
that's the only reason i came to japan
will you help connor clean his room he
probably still needs it
it's a little weird but yeah i would i
would love to if you raised your kids in
japan what do you think the first
language would be oh god that is a weird
one to think about i guess it would
speak japanese if they went to school
but then they would speak english with
us
and japanese and swedish
and italian
this poor child
what's your definition of a perfect
lifestyle living your life freely doing
the things that you want to do with no
pressure from other people i think maybe
part of growing up you realize that
there's so much pressures of what you do
you think it's your own choice but in
reality you made it for someone else and
that's how you end up living your life
without even realizing it so for me the
perfect lifestyle would just be
living your life the way you want to
sounds simple but
not always the case
i would say rarely
okay i think that's gone long enough
thank you guys for watching
super fun to answer your questions i
feel like i look so swedish here it's
insane
anyway i appreciate all the love and
support it really means so much to me i
didn't come here thinking i'm going to
start vlogging japan blog
but it's become something really really
fun and i love
i love all the love you guys are great
thank you fist